you know I worked weekends I didn't
believe in vacation and so I I really
pushed people to work hard have you ever
met a person who was a great reader when
they were young who was not successful
the way I tend to view problems this is
from a from a physics standpoint wanna
be happy build a life not just a
business
hey Jeff and Carmichael and this channel
was created to help you overcome the
number one challenge that is holding you
back it lack a belief in yourself you
watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you have Michael Jordan level talent at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn the seven best
lessons from Elon Musk Warren Buffett
and other billionaires
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one work hard with Bill Gates your early
days he describes yourself as a
nightmare boss there's a your words not
mine and was your were that work ethic
just very different to everybody else's
I was fanatical in my 20s
helping Microsoft lead the way in
software was the only thing that I
really focused on so you know I worked
weekends I didn't believe in vacation
and so I I really pushed people to work
hard teach and I was still learning how
to manage people particularly the
different skill sets the salespeople the
accounting people and so you know I I I
fortunately I think I'm a little bit
better now rule number two be a great
reader with Oprah Winfrey and I would
say reading is the strongest signal for
success in the future that I've ever
seen it is the strongest strongest
strongest I got my first job in radio
when I was 16 years old because I've
been in broadcasting since I was 16
years old but my first job I got because
I was a great reader when you are a
great reader you can articulate and
speak and command the English language
in ways that other people cannot and
people think you're a lot smarter than
you are
lots of times because you're great
reader have you ever met a person who
was a great reader when they were young
who was not successful you never never
it is the absolute best foundation ever
in life rule number three use physics
principles in your thinking with Elon
Musk in the way I tend to view problems
this is from it from a physics
standpoint and I think
physics is a good analytical framework
and one of the key things in physics is
to reason from first principles this is
contrary to the way most human reasoning
takes place which is by analogy
reasoning from first principles just
means that you figure out what are the
fundamentals what are the fundamental
truths or or things that are pretty
people are pretty sure of fundamental
truths and and can you build up to a
conclusion front from that are uniform
those principles and and then certainly
if you come up with some idea and it
appears to violate one of those
fundamental truths and you're probably
wrong or you should get a really big
prize or something like that
so this may seem like I don't know it
may be it may seem sort of obvious when
it's explained but it's actually not
what people do you it reasoning my
analogies is helpful because it's a
shortcut yeah and and it's and it's
mostly correct but but it tends to be
most incorrect when you're dealing with
new things because it's hard to
analogize to something really new also
if you want to have more confidence and
self-love check out my 254 series
they're free the link to join on the
description below you really have to
believe the Internet's going to be
mainstream a lot of people are gonna get
out there and use it become so skilled
so vigilant so flat-out fantastic at
what you do that your talent cannot be
dismissed it's so difficult to be a
small business born in China it took me
five months to bond 500 dollars rule
number four follow your dreams with Jack
Ma in my apartment where we started
eighteen founders and we aim high we
have a dream we say we want to make
become the top ten in tenant companies
or websites in the world guys at that
time we are ranking several meaning name
who is it won't be another ten or the
top ten of the world we want to make
this company last a hundred two years
and we don't know where's our pay next
month
well when you're poor if you have a
dreams you never feel poor you know what
we are doing so after we never say we
would be we will wing next year or we
win tomorrow we say we will weigh in 10
20 years 19 years past today we are the
top 10 websites coming to the
competition the world rule number 5 be
resourceful with Jeff Bezos my
grandparents would take me every summer
starting at age 4 every summer
kind of to give her a break really for
the whole summer so I'd be with my
grandparents and on their ranch in
Cotulla Texas which is halfway between
San Antonio and Laredo we lived in
Houston and so we would make the 5-hour
drive out to Cotulla they dropped me off
spend a couple days there that they go
back to Houston I'd spend the summer and
I went every day of the ranch with my
grandfather to help know a four-year-old
boy on a ranch in South Texas it's not a
lot of help but I didn't know that I
thought I was helping and and then it's
like by the time I was 16 I actually was
helping so I have you know I I can I can
suture up a prolapsed cow
I can fix windmills
my grandfather was so resourceful and
that he made his own veterinary needles
he would take a little piece of wire and
pound it flat with a was like a oxy
acetylene torch and then drill a little
hole through it and then we would do we
did all of our own veterinary work some
of the cattle even survived and
so we had but we had great fun out there
you know we built barns and welded
things and he bought a d6 Caterpillar
bulldozer used like 1955 model year for
$5,000 it was completely broken the
gears were stripped and then we spent
you know a whole summer repairing that
the first thing we had to do to repair
it was build a crane to take the gears
out of the transmission and so you know
what I learned from watching him was
just how resourceful he was he didn't
ever call a repairman he figured it out
rule number six have the right heroes
with Warren Buffett if you tell me who
your heroes are I can tell you how
you're going to turn out to quite an
extent by this point in life and I have
been extraordinarily lucky and that none
of my heroes ever let me down I mean I
the ones I came up with throughout their
lives that I've never felt that I've
been let down in any way with and number
one was my dad and had a huge impression
on me my wife who was heroes is one of
my heroes I mean she is you know in
terms of she's taught me a tremendous
amount and never seen anybody any better
with human beings and she is and you can
Yogi Bear again said you can you can
observe a lot just by watching and
I you know I I watched my dad and I have
watched her and I had a professor Ben
Graham back at Columbia and had a huge
impact on me so I have been lucky and
then I've had terrific heroes and they
they haven't let me down and and that
that takes you a long long way I've gone
through one or two periods word that
we're kind of tough in life but I'm not
any I mean everybody had had that but
what having the right heroes will take
it right through it I'm rule number
seven the last one before a very special
bonus step is do good with Mark
Zuckerberg I kind of think about what
we're doing today I'm very similarly to
how I thought about where we were at the
beginning you know it's you know I get
people all the time who come to me and
say all right well you're investing
billions of dollars in trying to put
Internet connectivity and in places
where you know we don't get paid for it
it's not something that will that will
make any money from for a very long
period of time if it works out but you
know it's this deep belief that you're
trying to make a change you're trying to
connect people in the world and I really
do believe that if you do something good
and if you help people out then
eventually some portion of that good
will come back to you and you may not
know upfront what it's going to be but
that's just been the guiding principle
for me and the work that we've done now
I have a special bonus clip from Mark
Cuban on how to find your path I think
you're gonna enjoy but before that it's
time for the three point landing
questions let's go from just watching
the video to taking action here we go
watch number one what can you do good on
today
number two who are three heroes that you
want to start modeling and number three
where do you need to just be more
resource and if you made it this far in
a video I want to celebrate you and give
me a hashtag believe in the comments as
well my dad did upholstery on cars so if
you've got a rip in your car seat you
would take it to where he worked
my mom did work odd jobs from wherever
and we were you know we had we lived in
a ok neighborhood but we weren't poor by
alongside but we were truly middle-class
and I over and over my dad didn't go to
college my mom didn't go to college and
so they would be done to me
you're going to college and they used to
make me work at odd jobs so that I would
learn the value of work and and you know
one I'd go where my dad worked doing it
with cars and he'd make me sweep the
hole and this place was nasty make me
sweep all the time you know try to get
me a job in a mill but couldn't give me
a job in a mill my mom wanted me to lay
carpet because she was worried about me
if I didn't have a trade and so she got
a friend of hers to try to get me to
teach me how to lay carpet and if you
ever go there's this little office in
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania if you trip over
the carpet that's where I learned how to
lay carpet and I was going through these
things I'm like this is just not me and
and I always had that that individual
spirit to say okay you know I can come
up with things that can make me money I
mean when I was nine I would sell
baseball cards when I was twelve I told
my dad I wanted a pair of basketball
shoes and it just so happens he was
playing poker with his buddies who are
all probably two rip-roaring drunk at
the time and I just didn't realize it
but I was like dad I want a new pair of
tennis shoes you know the the new beta
bullets were coming out or whatever they
were a new converse and he's like you
see those shoes on your feet they work
just fine when you have a job you can go
buy whatever you want I'm like dad I'm
12 I don't have a job and one of his
buddies stood up it was got strep but he
said hey I got I got a job for you
he had these boxes of garbage bags and
he's like I've got these boxes of
garbage bags I don't know what to do
with one you sell them I'm like cool you
know what do they cost me and they
literally were a box of a hundred these
blue garbage bags that he was some to me
for three bucks and then I would went
door-to-door it was like
hi my name is Mark
do you use garbage bags and I learned I
could sell is just like okay six bucks
you know I'll drop them off whenever you
need them just call me and I made some
money bought my shoes and you know and
that just gave me confidence and it took
off from there
if you want more lessons from us the
Buffett and other billionaires check out
the video right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there and I'm gonna tell
you something that a lot of people
ninety-nine percent of people disagree
with me on it wasn't as though in
creating these companies that so we
thought that we would be successful